do you know I think everything is my
fault like all of it
there has never been a better time to be
alive in the human race than right now
the motivation watch a top ten with the
lead nation
what's that belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and join
today's lessons from a man who went from
being born in the Soviet Union and
selling lemonade and baseball cards
growing up to wanting to become the
greatest entrepreneur of our generation
he's Gary Vaynerchuk and here's my take
on his top ten rules of success volume 9
also if you want to know what Gary Vee
and other successful entrepreneurs have
to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below
the reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one take on responsibility the reason I
say the thing that if there's anybody
that ever looked like you that made it
then there's no excuse is cuz I believe
it you know it's really hard here in our
argument and that your friend tells you
that's great Gary but both my parents
were alcoholics and that really me up
right now you're on the defense that's a
good first punch by them am i cool we
don't need to use me if anybody has ever
been successful that had two alcoholic
parents which by the way I know of three
well then now what's your Excuse Karen
we are just so interested in blaming
everybody else and excuses cuz we don't
want to take on responsibility and some
were a long time ago I went completely I
only take I do you know I think
everything is my fault
like all of it like I think it's weirdly
cloudy outside right now and not nice
out my fault
like his scar my fault
like I just default into my fault and
everybody tries to do everything else
the other way and let me tell you how
good life becomes when you take on
responsibility it gets real good uh some
of you and there's a lot of you that
follow me you know why I keep bringing
up the last scene of eight-mile the
Eminem movie how many people have seen
that movie great the last scene they go
into the battle he makes fun of himself
the whole time because it leaves the
other person with nothing the leverage
is in being accountable of everything
the leverage is exposing your weaknesses
I proudly talked about passing on uber
twice being a DNF student you know I
proudly talk about my shortcomings right
I can't wait for more bad things to
happen I mean it because I will talk
about them because what you're so
imperfect q rule number two be practical
we are in a remarkable time for all the
things you may be worried about left
right up down there has never been a
better time to be alive in the human
race than right now
medicine life expectancy poverty every
issue we have
better you know the best people to talk
about what's going on in America or 90
year olds they should not everybody
they're like it's bad oh my this woman
made me laugh sorry it's like 92 year
old woman stopped me in the street and I
keep doing what you're doing I'm like
thank I mean she looked like 190 I was
like thinking I got talked in for a
second she's like and by the way these
women and she's wrong but it was still
funny she goes these woman if I didn't
have somebody grab my ass every day in
the office I was pissed like I get it I
was like don't say that in public she's
like public
I was like man 92 is from gangsters I'm
obsessed with practicality I'm obsessed
with practicality
people think I'm a destructor or you
know no strict predictor or right I'm
practical Facebook and Instagram ads are
grossly underpriced if you go home
tonight and google how to run Instagram
story ads and learn how to do that and
then make a video or picture and run
Instagram story ads for whatever you're
trying to do in life become the mayor
here sell some peanuts
kombucha get people to sign up for your
you know track team I don't care what I
don't want a fish comes from you think
you can sign people up for a track team
anyway nonetheless
an Instagram story ad will work better
than anything else you can do if you
care about people 15 to 55 15 to 45 if
you care about people 30 to 75 Facebook
works better than anything like all your
dreams whatever that may be simple
dreams like making four hundred dollars
more a month so you can save it and take
your family to Walt Disney this year all
your dreams like the amount of people
that are affected by making two hundred
dollars more a month is staggering the
fact that I know that if you literally
stop listening to me right now took out
your phone went to Craigslist went to
the for sale section clicked on the free
section within the for sale section took
your car got up left in the middle Mikey
know and picked up eight things went
home took one picture on your phone not
like the old days where the phone you
take the discount of putting a computer
no not that which is oh by the way the
old days you know 11 years ago and you
know just take a picture of the thing
and post it on Facebook marketplace and
post it for 20 to 80 dollars that
literally in the next 48 hours you would
have $200 more I'm obsessed with
practicality everything I talk about
feels so real it just might take 11
years and a lot of people don't have 11
years they don't have 11 years because
they're not wanting to put him to work
to be happy for the rest of their life
they'd rather complain they'd rather
blame somebody else rule number three
love the game what are the qualities
that you think made for a true and a
successful entrepreneur what
she or he has to love the game for me a
purebred entrepreneur she or he loves
the journey not the stuff you know one
of the things I struggle with in the
current state of entrepreneurship is a
lot of people want the vacations the
watch is you know even even the context
is this you guys have such an incredible
imagery I think it's remarkable
who doesn't want fine things in life
yeah but I think that if you're in the
game just for the fine things in life
for the bottles and the models and the
private planes I think you're gonna lose
and it definitely is not my definition
of an entrepreneur and my definition of
an entrepreneur is somebody who can't
live without doing their thing and
trying to create literally suffocated
rule number four find your why but all
the time because if they're doing it for
money I think the bigger question is
what do you want the money for is it
blocking and insecurities that to get
the girl is it is it is because you're
trying to amass as much as you can
because you don't actually don't like
working and you want to live it the
reason so many people say fail in life
and business is their model is let me
get the money so that I can enjoy and
relax they think of it it's like
hoarding it and then eating it all over
time so our retirement and uh listen
it's such a bad way to because then
you're feeling the pressure of like
massing so that you can then enjoy I
think the bigger question is like what
are you up to like why are you doing it
like what's up I just think a lot of
people are trying to achieve success
and use fame or money as makeup for a
situation that they're just not happy
about like you have to figure out how to
make your day in and day out happy rule
number five surround yourself with
positivity
you want to get out honestly I get it
but you understand there's no
alternative there's only two choices
here you stay on that roof in each four
years to be more used to four years or
you bounce now it's not common in the UK
but people do it or you don't
life's about a very simple option these
are do you know if you're gonna need
your pods in and listen to positivity
24/7 you understand when your
surroundings are your insides got to be
positive in fact here even here maybe
halfway home
[Music]
I know when you're 14 or more years so
you stay and keep staying which is more
likely just fine
you gotta put positivity in their peers
do you understand I promise you
otherwise you just dwell and you go down
a spiral that you don't want to go down
you understand rule number six live your
passion by the way this whole notion of
like you can do anything and all this
stuff let me just tell you it's stupid
hard reality is most of you are just
average ly talented right like you're
not gonna over index in anything too
crazy here's the good news
this is not about how much money you
make or how talented you are this is
about being happy
everybody here regardless of how
talented they are in making money or art
or what-have-you
has they're super into you love Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles your whole life
could be about Michelangelo it could and
here's what really with me in this
internet age you could have a podcast
around Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
you could buy Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle memorabilia Craigslist and
Facebook and Etsy and then flip it on a
different platform because you're so
knowledgeable because that's the pizza
eating Leonardo that I'm just fascinated
about what you happens when you go all
in under passion you're committed to it
and you use the infrastructure of this
you living your life for 80 years as the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle expert in
this is getting funnier to me by the
second
making 83k a year in ads on your
podcasts the flip some miraculous reason
somebody paid you two thousand dollars
to go to a bush-league Comic Con thing
that person making sixty-two thousand a
year being the TMT expert versus them
making seventy seven thousand a year
being an admin in a company where they
hate their life 9:00 to 5:00 that Delta
is something I will go to the grave on
because it is what I want to articulate
to everybody the the unbelievable level
of practicality to douche round stuff
you like and here's the big part how
many people under 40 let me just start
with this group if you just really took
what I'm talking about
became an expert of Facebook and
Instagram really understood the fact
that you could take a leap for two years
move back in home move in together cut
your expenses I don't give a [ __ ] the
fact that you can do that for two or
three years and if it doesn't work out
you can go back to getting a job that's
nuts that's nuts
rule number seven reinvest in your
business I don't think you get to judge
what somebody does with the fruits of
their labor yeah for me I think that
that's what's amazing about anything
which is there's many different many
different definitions for you you know
go out work your face off win and reward
yourself with something is exactly right
for me the reward is pouring more of the
dollars and energy into the company not
buying stuff for myself it's one in the
same yeah it's one in the same to me I I
think it's amazing if somebody wants to
buy an Armani suit or a $5,000 pair of
belt or a diamond ring for a hundred
thousand
I don't but that doesn't mean that's
right or wrong what I'm doing with that
same hundred thousand instead of a ring
is I'm hiring two more people because
I'm trying to buy the jewelry company
not a piece of the jewelry rule number
eight don't care about the judgments of
others the biggest vulnerability
everybody has here is they're worried
about somebody else's judgment
the reason there is no moment of clarity
is you don't want to jump you don't want
to jump because you're worried if you
lose what people gonna say starting with
your parents your friends your
contemporaries my ability to not truly
truly care about other people's opinions
has been the foundation of my happiness
I respect people's opinions I just I
just don't care about their judgment of
me I've flip-flopped about project
management at vaynermedia like so many
times and I don't worry if somebody
hears like make a decision or like
you're stupid or like what the [ __ ] or
why are we always change it like go work
at great advertising rule number nine
have selfless goals the reason I will
never achieve my goals is my goals at
that place so these are people achieve
their goals is because their goals was a
number of money if your goal is an
amount of money you've lost so the
reason it's empty is what you want to be
a millionaire so what happens next is
gonna make ten million a year like what
a hundred million really it's the wrong
goals my biggest goals is to be the most
impactful entrepreneur of this
generation by bringing the most value to
all the entrepreneurs that's gonna take
me my whole life so you need to change
your goal
from something that's selfish because
something that's selfless because then
it will pick through the rest of your
life and rule number 10 the last home
before a very special bonus clip is live
life without regrets I should really go
to our time at home one day and
volunteer and just talk to them it won't
make you want to do every minute of your
life because when you're 90 and you're
not mobile and you're tired and it's
over you can't do it you can't do it
they can't build that company wanted you
can't spend that time with your kid you
its regret and if drives how old are you
time it's a it's a balance of regret and
patience like you can go hard on fun for
three years do nothing right wake up and
be young as the amount of people who are
watching this right now maybe even in
this room that are sad men and women
that they didn't go for it and didn't
make the move and didn't try that regret
is a hell of a lot longer and more
painful and more drawn out than the
instant rejection of going for it it's
just the way it is like even if you
think of random dumb stuff like not
asking out that person in high school or
so there's stuff lingers it's the stuff
that you don't do that bothers you and
so for the purebred entrepreneurs in
here that haven't decided to make that
leap or take that at bat I implore you
to do so right away because this window
closes - now I've got a really special
bonus clip from Gary Vee on how to hold
yourself accountable that I think you're
gonna really enjoy but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
questions time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking action in your business and your
life so here we go question number one
what is your why number two how can you
surround yourself with more positivity
today and number three what is one
regret that you need to let go of
this is the KPI buying stuff not having
a lot of followers dummy a successful
CEO happiness and happiness never
happens or you're fronting
so my friends listen be patient one of
the biggest reasons so many people have
said is they don't even realize they're
not faking
they don't realize that they happen
and house over the patient's because
things have been subsidized for whatever
reason
can be a million different things often
parents
or
I'll give you another fake environment
just living in a half glass empty world
before he started lost because who
decided can't win
government's dump where the game is
rigged or it's not for you somebody put
into your head that you can't win
there's no shine another fake
environment
you can do this but the reality is you
have to get real serious about
things which is
really puttin yourself
100% get real happy when you realize
you're in control accountability my
friends accountability Trump's
entitlement in the game of happiness
which leads to 100% success on your
terms raise your standard Apple at the
core its core value is that means that
people need passion can change the way
people not one drop of my self-worth
depends on your it's supposed to mean
if you like this video check out the one
we did on the power of habit I think
you're gonna really enjoy it's right
next to me continue to believe and I'll
see you there we are what we repeatedly
do change doesn't just happen at this
level of behavior but when do you have
to change the environment make a damn
schedule